[Music]
you had some edible marijuana desserts
yeah refrigerator and there was a little
accident that happened at home is that
true yeah my 83 year old mother was
visiting you can see where this goes
right and so she ate she didn't like the
taste of the cheese cake it was a
marijuana cheesecake and it was in a bag
that said medical but she wanted to
never heard of Medical cheesecake like
it's mechanical cheesecake yeah it's
like cheesecake made with the pusher
yeah so she didn't like that she took a
bite she didn't like the taste of the
cheese cake so she melted an entire
candy bar of medical marijuana chocolate
over and ate back not knowing any of it
had marijuana in it no she didn't care
cuz it was a snack yeah and then she
started getting all woozy and we had to
rush her to the emergency room he had
taken 26 doses and you said she's pretty
straight-laced she doesn't never even
had a drink in her life or anything like
that
so so she was just bounced I mean she
was too but she's been floating she was
better first it first she was laughing
look at that tree and then and then the
what i'ma call it were you like vomit
and it hits the wall a lot of that yeah
she had to go in and they had to give
her you know an IV and everything is
their blood pressure drop you can't
overdose on marijuana which is lucky but
for all people that can make their blood
pressure really drop and she had all
that it was terrifying
and this or two weeks later I hadn't
called her since she went back home and
so she left a message on my phone it was
so funny she goes what does a [ __ ] have
to do OD to get you to call her
these very warming mom daughter stories
alright
you